George Washington's crossing of the
Delaware River in December 1776 if
you're interested in finding out about
the authors and books featured on
history on book TV as it us online at
book TV org and click on history on book
TV Moyers on America is a new collection
of essays from PBS host Bill Moyers
topics include Iraq and media bias the
program's an hour good evening my name
is Lewis pizzetta thank you for joining
us tonight a year ago the man I have the
great pleasure of introducing to you
gave a speech on the subject of
progressivism in America in addition to
making some fascinating comparisons
between the presidencies of William
McKinley and George W Bush between a
time of unchecked corporate and imperial
power and the world we live in today he
also talked about the relevancy of a
progressive movement here is some of
what he said ideas have power as long as
they are not frozen in doctrine but
ideas need legs the eight-hour day the
minimum wage the conservation of natural
resources and the protection of our air
water and land women's rights and civil
rights free trade unions Social Security
and a civil service based on merit all
of these were launched as citizens
movements what's right and good doesn't
come naturally you have to stand up and
fight for it as if the cause depends on
you because it does our guest tonight
was one of the organizers of the Peace
Corps
a spokesperson for President Lyndon
Johnson publisher of Newsday a
correspondent for CBS News and a
producer of many series for Public
Television he joins us tonight with a
new book that draws on the nation's
history and his own it is appropriately
titled Moyers on America a journalist
and his time
it's really a great pleasure to
introduce to you bill moyers
thank you
thank you for that welcome and thank you
Lou for that introduction it's often
said of those of us in television we
don't need an introduction but that's
not true and I'll tell you about three
things that happened to me on one day a
few years ago I had been doing a summer
see I was at CBS at the time I've been
doing a summer series with Charles
Kuralt the late great correspondent
Charles Kuralt
and I was also the senior news analyst
succeeding Eric Sevareid on the CBS
Evening News with Dan Rather August came
and as I did in those years every August
I went down to see my parents in East
Texas I took a cab from CBS at 524 West
57th out to LaGuardia got in the cab put
my bag in the trunk the the luggage had
the famous CBS logo the blue and black I
that you know so well but it didn't have
my name on it so when we got to the
LaGuardia the porter reached into the
back of the cab and pulled off the
luggage he looked at it he looked up at
me looked back at it looked at me looked
at it looked at me he said you know are
you on a soap opera I started to say yes
the CBS Evening News with Dan Rather but
I didn't I didn't think my good friend
Dan would appreciate that I went on
checked in was sitting there reading the
New York Times and noticed that over the
logo of The Times came a shock of white
hair and I pull the paper down I was
looking right into the eyes of a of an
elderly senior citizen much older than
you and she looked at me and I looked at
her and she said I know you who are you
true story I flew to Shreveport
Louisiana the airport nearest my home in
East Texas was waiting for that same bag
and another lady came up to me and she
said oh oh she said I just love your
work mr. Carlton
but she said you look different in
person from how you look on television
and I said yes ma'am I own television
I'm fatter and bolder it's the she said
so Helen she said that's all I love you
both what the moral is you know so much
for notoriety
I'm the other bill
I never even inhale I'd have even smoked
I didn't drink until I was 26 and then
it was just sassafras I mean that's what
comes from being raised a real Baptist
in Texas but I admire his work by the
way and intend to read his book after
you've read mine I'm a journalist who
asked questions but I prefer in an
audience like this to answer them and
after I've read a few excerpts from
Moyers on America I look forward to
taking your questions
since the we're approaching the fourth
of July weekend I'll start with a little
essay I have here on the Declaration of
Independence what can I say about the
Declaration of Independence that hasn't
already been said how does a mere
journalist do justice to the power and
poetry of the words in that document
sometimes I think we should just kneel
in front of it I know many people have a
problem with the Declaration in its
eighteenth-century context they consider
it discriminatory exclusionary and
offensive to women blacks and minorities
right now there's a ruckus in New Jersey
where the state legislature has before
it a bill that would require children to
begin classes with the Pledge of
Allegiance followed by a passage of the
Declaration quote we hold these truths
to be self-evident that all men are
created equal one New Jersey Democrat
says that speaking those words would be
repugnant to little girls and a state
senator says black children should not
have to repeat the words of a wealthy
slave-owning southerner I understand
those feelings they come from deep
wounds I might have had a hard time
repeating them too if my ancestors have
been torn from their family sold on the
block
by the lash and worked like animals
surely it galls a person to have your
neighbor Revere as sacred a document
whose author denied your own humanity
while becoming a god-like hero in the
national pantheon
but I'd welcome the chance where our
teacher in New Jersey to hold up the
Declaration to my students and say to
them listen children now we're going to
read between the lines between the lines
is a story that takes us deeper into the
human condition and the American
experience than any civics book think
very hard about this the hands that
wrote those words also stroked the
breasts and caressed the thighs of a
woman named Sally Hennings the same
voice that read those words aloud by
candlelight to other Patriots whispered
in the slave woman's ear other words far
too intimate for parchment this slave
woman who was the half-sister of his
late wife bore him six children how do
we know DNA tells us historical Rhett
research and forensic investigations
supported and not even the Thomas
Jefferson Memorial Foundation denies it
it's true the man who wrote these noble
words had a long-term sexual
relationship with the slave and the
children she bore by him his children
were slaves themselves one guest at
Monticello who looked up at dinner one
evening was startled to see a young
servant who was the spitting image of
the master at the table Jefferson never
acknowledged those children as his own
and as he grew older he relied more and
more on slavery to keep him afloat
financially when he died his slaves were
sold to satisfy his creditors
all except Sally she threw an obscure
passage in Jefferson's will was the only
slave at Monticello to secure the
freedom of her children
two of those children settled in Ohio
where their own descendants increased
during the year some living as blacks
and some as whites two centuries later
race still divides them some consider
themselves black though they look white
and some consider themselves white
although they have known black ancestors
the family of one white descendant
turned on her when she decided to seek
out her relatives among the black
Hennings and bitter feelings have risen
of late because these black Hennings
won't membership in the Jefferson Family
Association and the right to be buried
in the Jefferson family cemetery so what
would I tell these New Jersey children I
would tell these New Jersey children
that Jefferson got it right when he
wrote those noble words about life
liberty and the pursuit of happiness he
had to know the flesh-and-blood woman in
his arms was his equal in her desire for
life her longing for liberty her passion
for happiness my friend Mortimer Adler
once said of the declaration that
whatever things are really good for any
human beings are really good for all
other human beings the happier good life
is essentially the same for all a
satisfaction of the same needs inherent
in human nature yet all Sally Hemings
got from her long sufferance perhaps it
was all she sought from what may have
gone into a secret unacknowledged love
was that he let her children go one of
the oldest petitions in the human
experience let my children go this he
did at death for them but not for his
other slaves he needed the money he got
it right you see but he lived it wrong
he got it right for the same reason he
lived it wrong he was human so addicted
to intellect that had overruled his
heart so enthralled to place and
privilege that he could send the noblest
sentiments ringing around the
but not allow them to lodge in his own
house so much a creature of his times
was he that even when he knew the truth
he lived the lie Thomas Jefferson
embodies the oldest and longest war of
all the war of the self it is what Saul
of Tarsus who became the Apostle Paul
understood when he wrote I do not do
what I want to and what I detest I do it
is what Emily Dickinson understood when
she wrote I felt a cleaving in my mind
as if my brain has split I tried to
match it seem by scene but could not
make it fit what I would want those
children in New Jersey to know is this
the man who wrote the words of the
Declaration understood a great truth no
man is fit to be a master Prince Pope
politician plantation overseer whoever
puts on the brief cloak of power is
reluctant to take it off again left to
their own devices
monarchs masters and ministers of state
our church will define the meaning of
things by edict and resolve conflicts by
Fiat concealing their own self-interest
in platitudes of piety Jefferson's
Declaration proclaimed an end to
arbitrary rule and the revolution
produced a republic where the consent of
the government meant that from now on
the powers that be the elites would have
to live up to their words or eat them
now it would be up to the people
themselves to define what those words
would mean in the real world of politics
since this document replaced biblical
law with natural law there would be no
fixed dogmatic criteria to which the
people would appeal for guidance and no
authority apart from themselves upon
whom they could rely we were on our own
even Sally Hemings descendants
would one day have their say this is
from the opening essay in the book which
was based upon the speech Bleu referred
to that I gave on the 4th of June last
year to the annual gathering of the
progressives meeting in Washington and
this sort of sets the context for both
my life and my journalism and this book
on my 16th birthday in 1950 I went to
work for the daily newspaper in the
small East Texas town where I grew up it
was a good place to be a cub reporter
small enough to navigate but big enough
to keep me busy and learning something
every day I soon had a stroke of luck
some of the old-timers were on vacation
or out sick and I got a sign to cover
what came to be known as the housewives
rebellion 15 women in my hometown
decided not to pay the Social Security
withholding tax for their domestic
workers they argued that social security
was unconstitutional that imposing it
was taxation without representation and
that here's my favorite part
requiring us to collect the tax is no
different from requiring us to collect
the garbage they hired themselves a
lawyer none other than Martin dyes jr.
the former Congressman best known are
worse known for his work as head of the
House Committee on American activities
in the 1930s and 1940s he was no more
effective at defending rebellious women
than he had been protecting against
communist subversives and eventually the
housewives wound up holding their noses
and paying the taxes the stories I wrote
for the local paper were picked up by
the Associated Press one day the
managing editor called me over and
pointed to the ap ticker beside his desk
moving across the wire was a notice
citing one bill moyers and the paper for
the reporting we had done on the
rebellion that hooked me and in one way
or another after a detour through
seminary and then in the politics and
government first bail I've been covering
the class war ever since those women in
Marshall Texas were its advance guard
not bad people
they were regulars at church their
children were my friends many of them
were active in community affairs and
their husband
were pillars of the business and
professional class they were respectable
and upstanding citizens all so it took
me a while to figure out what had
brought on that spasm of reactionary
rebellion it came to me one day much
later they simply couldn't see beyond
their own prerogatives fiercely loyal to
their family to their clubs charities
and congregations fiercely loyal in
other words to their own kind they
narrowly defined membership and
democracy to include only people like
them the women who washed in iron their
laundry wiped their children's bottoms
made their husband's beds and cook their
family's meals these women too would
grow old and frail sick and decrepit
lose their husbands and face the ravages
of time alone with nothing to show from
their years of labor but the creases in
their brow and the knots on their
knuckles so big even on the distaff side
of lazy fare security was personal then
not social and what justice existed what
injustice existed this side of heaven
would no doubt be redeemed beyond the
pearly gates in one way or another this
is the oldest story in America the
struggle to determine whether we the
people is a spiritual idea embedded in a
political reality one nation indivisible
or merely a charade masquerading as
piety and manipulated by the powerful
and privileged to sustain their own way
of life at the expense of others I
should make it clear that I don't harbor
any idealized notion of politics and
democracy after all I worked for Lyndon
Johnson nor do I romanticize the people
you should read my mail or listen to the
vitriol virtually spat at my answering
machine I understand what the politician
meant who said of the Texas House of
Representatives if you think these guys
are bad
you should see their constituents but
there is nothing idealized or romantic
about the difference between a society
whose Arrangements roughly serve all its
citizens and one whose institutions have
been converted into a stupendous fraud
that difference can be the difference
between democracy and oligarchy that's
part of the opening essay here's a one a
commentary an essay I did on the air on
our Friday night show call now with Bill
Moyers that keep bringing down the wrath
of
this was done before the invasion of
Iraq Iraq is not Vietnam but war is war
some may recall that I was press
secretary to Lyndon Johnson during the
escalation of war in Vietnam like the
White House today we didn't talk very
much about what the war would cost in
the beginning we weren't sure and we
didn't really want to know too soon
anyway we were afraid of what telling
Congress and the public the to cost of
the war would do to the rest of the
budget the money for education poverty
Medicare in time however we had to
figure it out and come clean
it wasn't the price tag that heard as
much as it was the body count the dead
were coming back in such numbers that
LBJ grew morose and sometimes took to
bed with the covers pulled above his
eyes as if he could avoid the ghosts of
young men marching around in his head I
thought of this the other day when
President Bush spoke of the loss of
American lives in Iraq he said I'm the
one who will have to look the mothers in
the eye LBJ said almost the same thing
no president can help but think of the
mothers the widow's the orphans the
father's to the hearts of a father can
break from grief mr. Bush is amassing a
mighty American Armada in the Middle
East incredible firepower surely he
knows that even a clean war a war fought
with laser beams long-range missiles
high-flying bombers and remote controls
gets down and dirty especially for the
other side we forget their mothers and
fathers on the other side I've often
wondered about the parents of Vietnamese
children burned by our napalm or of
Afghan children smashed and broken by
our bombs on the NBC Nightly News one
evening I saw a report from Afghanistan
with aerial photography of little white
lights heat images of people on foot
about to be attacked as they fled a
mosques
where they al-qaida are just the
faithful at worship will never know
their kin do and so will the mothers and
fathers in Iraq Saddam won't mind the
losses even if he escapes the death of
his own people seems never to perturb
the man as for us well the spoils of
victory include amnesia ah the seduction
of war the adrenaline that flows to men
behind desks at the very thought that
armies will march missiles will fly
ships will sail on their command our
Secretary of Defense has a plaque on his
desk that reads aggressive fighting for
the right is the noblest sport the world
affords I don't think so
war may sometimes be a necessity to
treat it as sport is obscene to launch a
numata against who sayings to launch an
armada against Hussein's own hostage
population of people who have not fired
a shot at us in anger seems accrued and
poor alternative to shrewd disciplined
diplomacy and the forging of a true
reliance acting in the name of
international law don't get me wrong
Vietnam didn't make me a dove it made me
read the Constitution government's first
obligation is to defend its citizens
there's nothing in the Constitution that
says it's permissible for a great nation
to launch a pre-emptive attack against a
captive nation unprovoked
unprovoked the noble sport of war
becomes the murder of the innocent and
then one night in anger I guess more
than anything if you were watching the
show you saw me put on an American flag
and I did this little essay I wore my
flag on air tonight until now I hadn't
thought it necessary to display a little
metallic icon of patriotism for everyone
to see
it was enough to vote pay my taxes
perform my civic duties speak my mind
and do my part to raise our kids to be
good Americans as they are sometimes I
would offer a small prayer of gratitude
that I've been born in a country whose
institutions sustain me whose Armed
Forces protected me and whose ideals
inspired me I offered my heart's
affections in return it no more occurred
to me to flaunt the flag on my chest and
it did to pin my mother's picture on my
lapel to prove her son's love mother
knew where I stood so does my country
sometimes they even tuck a Valentine in
my tax returns on April 15
so why wear it well I put it on to take
it back the flag has been hijacked and
turned into a logo the trademark of a
monopoly on patriotism almost Sunday
morning talk shows official chests
appeared on with the flag as if it were
the Good Housekeeping Seal during the
State of the Union address did you
notice Bush and Cheney wearing the flag
how come no administration's patriotism
is ever in doubt only its policies and
the flag bestows no immunity from era
most galling are all those moralistic
ideologues in Washington sporting the
flag in their lapels while writing books
running websites and publishing
magazines attacking dissenters as an
American there are people whose ardor
for war grows disproportionately to
their distance
the fighting they belong to the same
league as those swarm of corporate
lobbyists prowling Capitol Hill with
flags and their lapels trolling for tax
breaks even as they call for more
spending on war so I put on the flag as
a modest repost to men with flags in
their lapels who shoot missiles from the
safety of Washington think tanks or
approve of bribing governments to join
the Coalition of the Willing or argue
that sacrifice is good as long as they
don't have to make it I put it on to
remind myself that the flag belongs to
the country not to the government that
one is not an American to see war except
in self-defense as a failure of moral
imagination political nerve and
diplomacy come to think of it standing
up to your government can mean standing
up for your country
few years ago we my wife and I she's the
president of public affairs television
and creator of some of the best ideas
and executive producers on the best
series we've done a few years ago we did
a series called on on our own terms
about death and dying in America I we
were told by by a lot of people around
the country nobody would watch it it
turned out to be one of the most
successful series that we have done in
my 33 years of television so I in this
book with an essay based upon that
series called aging and I'm just going
to take a few highlights summit before I
move on to your questions when the
invitation to join AARP arrived in the
mail I assumed it must have been wrongly
addressed then one day I looked in the
mirror and a senior citizen was looking
back staring at me with someone old
enough to be a member of the American
Association of Retired people born as
some peer once described our time before
radar credit card split atoms laser
beams and ballpoint pins before
pantyhose dishwashers clothes dryers
electric blankets air conditioners drip
drop drip dry clothes and before man
walked from the moon before television
before penicillin before polio shots
frozen foods Xeroxes plastic and contact
lenses and the pill I never thought much
about growing old
most of us journalists are so obsessed
with the here and now that we don't
think about the future growing old
happened only at the end of the trip lot
like arriving at the depot depot after a
long train ride one day we'd get off the
train and be old it was a promising
destination my cousin in Texas sent me a
column entitled how to tell your aging
it had been written with the bias of a
time when it was socially acceptable to
mock the old aging it said it's when the
gleam in your eyes is from the Sun
hitting your bifocals when you feel like
the night after and you haven't been
anywhere when your little black book
contains only names ending in MD when
you finally reach the top of the ladder
and find it leaning against the wrong
all when you decide to procrastinate but
never get around to it when your mind
makes contract your body can't meet when
you know all the answers but nobody
asked you the questions when you're
seventeen around the neck forty-four
around the waist and 96 around the golf
course when your favorite part of the
newspaper is twenty-five years ago today
the author went on but I didn't that was
enough of me I didn't like the spin old
happened to others it didn't happen to
me but that fellow in the mirror the one
with thinning hair graying all over with
little islands of brown floating and
unwelcome places on his face staring
back at me through trifocals who did I
think that was from a corner of my brain
came a half-remembered epigram from long
ago age has crept up on the unperceived
for his part innocent at council it is
time to be old to take in sale but I
stared back hard at the strange in the
mirror and said to hell with you and
decided not to shave right then but I
knew that the very experience of time
was making me an expert in aging against
my will I decided to go for the good
news about growing old and I found it
we're living longer in the forty five
hundred years from the Bronze Age for
the year 1900 life expectancy increased
twenty-seven years and in the short
period from 1900 to now it increased by
at least that much again the change has
been so dramatic it is currently
estimated that of all the human beings
who have ever lived half are currently
alive and with the baby boomers turning
50 years old by 2010 there will be as
many seniors as there are people under
the age of 20 so that's good news
death waits longer to come calling when
I was born before penicillin the median
age at death was 52 now it's 76 studies
have shattered the myths about aging
that help oh that hell older people
hostage to caricature and stereotype to
summarize them is to affirm that we no
longer believe that to be old is
inevitably to be sick we now know that
we can reduce our risk of disease and
disability
nor do we still believe that old dogs
can't learn new tricks for we know that
old age can be a time for learning that
trained elders and this comes from very
long study done by the MacArthur
Foundation can even do better at member
games than untrained young people we no
longer believe that our course in old
age is predetermined
we know from strong scientific evidence
that successful aging is not for the
most part inherited and that we are
largely responsible for our own old age
we have the capacity to enhance the
chance of maintaining high mental and
physical ability as we grow older nor do
we any longer believe that lights may be
on but the voltage is low for we know
that the basic human need for
affectionate physical contact persists
throughout life and so does the capacity
for giving it the key is attitude
what is attitude macarthur study answers
that question with an anecdote from
satchel paige the legendary black
pitcher who was as famous for his fast
answers as far as fastball he began
pitching at the age of 17 and was for
many years restricted what was then
called the Negro baseball league born
near the turn of the century he was
already a veteran at the pitcher's mound
when the racial barrier was relaxed
however the decades rolled by and he
continued to pitch as he did so Paige
became purposely vague about his age a
subject of increasing speculation among
sports writers when one of them put the
question bluntly how old are you Paige
gave him a classic answer how would you
be if you didn't know how old you was
then I move to the subject of death I'd
rather not think about death especially
my own
Woody Allen famously said I'm not afraid
of dying I just don't want to be there
when it happens
same here Thomas Lynch the funeral
director and poet writes extensively
about his work at the intersection of
living and dying in an interview for my
series he says that though the two are
inextricably linked the distance we put
between ourselves and our death turns it
into an embarrassment or a spectacle we
go to see frightening movies we love to
see Arnold Schwarzenegger machine gun a
bazillion people all at once we like
death on that scale and we like it on
the scale where we can laugh about it
the Halloween thing but the normal
ground where people love and grieve
we're uncomfortable with that huge
middle ground
most of us occupy in which we form
lifelong attachments that are broken by
death we don't like to talk about that
we're reluctant to talk about death
because it's an uncomfortable subject it
reminds us we're mortal we're afraid of
the unknown we don't a burden our family
so we defer the pain of preparing for
the inevitable and we keep quiet about
it but it's no secret that we don't die
well in America this is a great place to
be sick because the odds are you'll get
well we have all this incredible medical
technology that's given us unprecedented
power to treat illness but that very
technology has also produced unintended
consequences that have changed the
experience of dying consequences that
include intense pain financial
devastation and loss of world loss of
self-determination before World War two
before antibiotics usually death came
quickly today while many people who age
are healthy and active many are enduring
prolonged deaths as a consequence of
chronic progressive disease accompanied
by great emotional physical existential
and spiritual suffering no one wants to
die that way we want a gentle closure a
good death and the series dealt with
that attempt to get good closure in my
latest series on ports and port
refueling with words the poet mark Doty
tells about his own
companion who died a difficult death
from AIDS this was a moment of profound
helplessness he told me our lives had
been scarred by the epidemic nothing had
so inscribed and transformed my own
experience as that whole constellation
of events I realized that all we had was
our ability to take care of each other
to stand with each other we had our
dreams we have the ways in which we
negotiated privately with malls it was
imperative or so it seemed to me said
mark Doty that we see ourselves as being
part of a community of caretakers
dreamers and mortal beings what a
difference it can make if all of us
could realize that vision could see
ourselves as a community of caretakers
dreamers and mortal beings who could do
something about a health care system
that lets so many people die deaths they
despised in places they deplore we need
a new language to talk about these
things in our own and on our own terms
residents tell me they've come through
seven years of medical school without a
single course in end-of-life care in one
survey only 14% of the doctors said they
had substantive conversations about the
prognosis with their patients who are
dying many doctors simply don't
understand the hope for a good death
partly because they fear talking about
it would cause their patients to quit
fighting I've tried over the last year
the last year of doing the series to
imagine my own death what I want for
myself is what everyone wants a gentle
dignified death free of pain attended by
the people I love who love me back
imagining this I can more truthfully
answer the question people have been
asking me ever since the broadcast air
wasn't it depressing working more than a
year on a series about death and dying
the answer is not at all
the reason is perhaps best illustrated
by this story in the summer of 1922 a
Paris newspaper concocted an elaborate
scenario for its readers an American
scientist announces the world will end
or at least that such a huge part of the
continent will be destroyed and in such
a sudden way that premature death will
be the certain fate of hundreds of
people
if this prediction were confirmed the
newspaper asked what do you think would
be its effects on people between the
time when they acquire the
aforementioned certainty and the moment
of apocalypse and what would you do in
this last hour one of the readers who
responded was Marcel Proust he said I
think that life would suddenly seem
wonderful to us if we were threatened to
die as you say just think of how many
projects Travels love affairs studies it
our life hides from us made invisible by
our laziness which certain of a future
delays them incessantly but at all but
let all of this threaten to become
impossible forever
how beautiful it would become again ah
if only the Cataclysm doesn't happen
this time
we won't miss visiting new galleries of
the Louvre throwing ourselves at the
feet of Miss X making a trip to India
the Cataclysm doesn't happen we don't do
any of it because we find ourselves back
in the heart of normal life where
negligence where negligence
dedenne's desire and yet we shouldn't
have needed the Cataclysm the love life
today it would have been enough to think
that we are humans
and that death may come this evening
so it may meanwhile
yeah welcome to New York can you hear me
yes I have a recollection of some years
ago you having a conversation with Henry
Steele comma jure I have a recollection
of you having a conversation on the
television in in with the Henry Steele
Commodore and you asking him what is the
difference if you could pick something
out between the way we do things now and
the way the founders of this country did
in colonial times then he and he's
saying that that we don't do things for
posterity anymore did we call it I do
recall that that conversation I did with
hinder still come in to the late great
historian was conducted in Lafayette
Square across the street from the White
House at the time of Watergate and we
talked about we put Watergate in
perspective and he made that statement
to me the great difference between then
and now he said is that we don't do
things for posterity
anymore that is in a way I don't know
journalists ask questions but rarely can
answer them I don't know this is what I
think this is why I ended a reading with
an essay on own death because at my
office today our team was talking about
living under this threat of terrorism
living in the in the claw of the threats
that have come to us and and and letting
the terrorists win
by always thinking about what might
happen next and and and I think that so
focuses us on the present that we tend
to forget as Jefferson said that this
nation should live for thousands of
generations and that each of us is his
is a part of the reciprocity of society
in fact I tell the story in the book of
my first anthropology course at the
University of Texas
the professor was Gilbert McAllister I
can see him now in a large classroom
like this striding up and down talking
about the time he had been a graduate
student a graduate student working among
the Apaches in West Texas east the one
thing he said that I remember this day
is that the word for grandfather and
gran
son in Apache is the same a way of in of
the natives saying that that there there
that that life is a clasp of two hands
that that we are reciprocally obligated
one generation to another that life is
all about reciprocity I think we have
lost that by living so so consequently
in the present I don't have the answer
to the question about how we get it back
except to think about it and and and
then the act on it yes I think I speak
for a lot of people when I say that I
think we're going to miss you when you
leave your great PBS program bill burr
is now you you have a chapter in your
book called journalism and democracy and
I would love to hear your thoughts on
the fact that George Bush had to go to
Ireland before he was questioned by a
brave journalist rather than you know
get such questions here in the United
States I do have a chapter in the book
on that I have a whole chapter on media
of which I'm one of course there are
still some wonderful courageous
independent journalists in this country
I think of you know Seymour Hersh comes
to mind his life in my mind is framed
about his great expose of me lie which
happened in our time and of Abu Ghraib
and what's happening in in Iraq three
things have happened I think in my
lifetime first of all I have to realize
why I'm so passionate about this I grew
up in the south
I grew up in the south that had paid a
terrible price as did the nation for
driving the truth out of the pulpit out
of the classroom and out of the newsroom
we southerners denied the truth about
slavery and it took a brutal and bloody
civil war to drive the truth home again
and then it took another hundred years
after a century of denial to fulfill the
victory of Appomattox to bring to
black Americans the promise of the
Declaration of Independence and it took
me a long time to realize the price we
had paid in the South for living in
denial and I realize a nation can dive
too many lies then I served in the
Johnson White House my first job was was
working with policy and legislation in
fact I was thinking as I came here about
40 years ago this summer got the call
about the three young men who'd been
killed in Mississippi the three young
civil rights workers have been killed in
Mississippi and that propelled us you
know in our commitment and Johnson's
commitment feeling immense eiated at
last by the presidency from his own
cultural tether as a from a conservative
state like Texas compelled us to the
Civil Rights Act of 64 the Voting Rights
Act of 65 and then the Civil Rights Act
of 66 that was the work I most enjoyed
he insisted that I become press
secretary after he'd run through two
others I said no the first time I said
no the second time the third time I
couldn't say no my shoulder still hurts
from it but I became press secretary and
we circle the wagons around around the
White House didn't listen sufficiently
to the David Halberstam the Morley Safer
z' and others who were reporting from
Vietnam the facts on the ground such as
we're getting today the facts on the
ground from Iran so those two
experiences being a southerner and being
in the Johnson White House have made me
passionate about about about the role of
journalism I don't want to make claim
too much for journalism but I don't want
to claim too little either and it's
essential to try to get it on the record
three things have happened to make it
harder to get on the record one is the
growth of secrecy I mean as John Dean
the Council of Watergate who blew the
whistle on Richard Nixon Watergate 30
years ago said on my show now with Bill
Moyers oh this is worse than Watergate
this administration has has built a
thick wall of secrecy around himself of
which the most striking metaphor is the
vice-president refusing to let us know
who what who with Ken Lay and others
wrote the energy task of energy policy
16,000 documents classified two years
ago twice the almost twice the number
four years ago this this obsession with
secrecy has made it harder to get at the
record the second thing that's happened
in my time has been the concentration of
ownership I mean a handful of companies
essentially control over half of the
outlets in this country big chains
mega-mergers mega profits driving
driving journalism to the to the margins
you don't see much serious journalism in
primetime on television and the news
holes in newspapers have been shrinking
because they make more money from
advertising than they do from the
editorial project and this concentration
of power has has has substantially
reduced the potency of journalism there
was never a golden age of of journalism
on that little paper or I got my start
which I loved no blacks were not didn't
figure in our reporting didn't figure in
our columns they weren't a part of the
recorded history of Marshall Texas in
that little paper there was no golden
age of newspapers but as the newspaper
conglomerates have gotten larger the
amount of news that we of serious news
real news has gotten were marginal I
know some of what did I mean by real
news well someone asked that of my
colleague Richard Reeves the journalist
and historian what's your definition of
real news and he said it's the news we
need to keep our freedoms we don't have
a lot of that it's hard to get and they
make it harder
the third thing has been the rise of
this vast right-wing quasi-official
partisan press you know stretching from
the editorial page of The Wall Street
Journal to the nattering Know Nothings
of talk radio to Rupert Murdoch's Empire
to all the corporate funded think tank
and marketing operations there's a huge
echo chamber of of a right-wing ideology
that serves two purposes one is to
promote right-wing ideas and second is
to come after anybody who dares offer a
dissenting opinion so you know this
began with the end of the Fairness
Doctrine in the 80s the Fairness
Doctrine required that if a television
station ran a opinion on this it had to
offer an alternative opinion of a
dissenting kind and Ronald Reagan's FCC
whose chairman said television is just a
toaster they banned the Fairness
Doctrine Congress put it back in and
Ronald Reagan vetoed so that the
Fairness Doctrine disappeared you had
the beginning of Rush Limbaugh three
hours a day there was a study done in a
number of major markets of a year ago
that said that found there were three
hundred and ten hours of a right-wing
talk radio in that one week compared to
10 hours of none right-wing talk radio
so you've got this huge megaphone in the
hands of ideologue now an ideologue is
someone whose worldview cannot be
changed because it admits no evidence to
the contrary and you never get evidence
to the contrary in this vast right-wing
and Bretta so secrecy a diminished
journalism at the expense of
conglomeration and the domination of a
right-wing ideological quasi-official
because they are the republican party's
organs publicity and propaganda organs
it's essentially responsible for makes
it harder to be an independent
journalist and to get her the Internet
is our salvation and a great fight of
the next ten years is to make sure that
access to the Internet is not itself
dominated by large conglomerations that
now dominate television and radio you
find a lot more about this in the
chapter on the media yes sir
you made me change a little bit the
nature of my question but because you
mentioned something about Regan but I am
going to kind of frame it this way I
think that the nature of the Democratic
Party changed after the 1964 Civil
Rights Act and it brings forth this idea
that was written about in this book
called chain-reaction we're in the 1968
election you had George Wallace who
developed the Southern Strategy and the
Democratic Party had to change its whole
focus and we're suffering that from the
40 year focus of conservatism in the
whole country
not just from Bush but from Reagan and
the reason I'm mentioning this is the
Monday after Reagan died the New York
Times wrote the real obituary in Todd
Purdum column which mentioned the
something a cast Sunstein had brought
forth that there's real no really no
left in this country it's everything on
a conservative spectrum of left
conservative center conservative and
right conservative and I'd like to know
what you have to say about that well
first of all you've probably heard the
story because it's widely circulated
that's true story that on the night
after he had signed the Civil Rights Act
of 1964 I went to Lyndon Johnson's
bedroom late in the evening and there
was the Bulldog edition of The
Washington Post president signs historic
bill but he looked very depressed I said
mr. president you should be exhilarated
you should this was a great day why why
do you look so down he said because I
think we just delivered the south to the
Republican Party for the rest of my life
and you're as he said what he meant by
that was that there would be a backlash
to granting bringing black southerners
all blacks but blacks others in
particular into the Democratic small D
system he was right I mean within hours
Baptist churches were pulling their kids
out of schools and setting up parochial
private schools and the backlash was
ferocious just as it had been
in the Reconstruction period a second
thing happened in 1979 when the Supreme
Court in buckley versus vallejo under
decision that was that was a suit that
was filed by then senator james buckley
republican conservative of new york and
and and and and enacted by a newly
appointed republican Supreme Court ruled
that money a speech money is the same as
free speech so that you know free speech
cost money I mean that's a strange thing
but since 1979 money has come to
dominate the American political system
huge corporations wealthy people
supporting both parties but both parties
have come to dominate overwhelm the
political process in historically in
American life there are two powerful
interests like a seesaw balancing the
Democratic experience one is the power
of organized economic interests the
others the power of organized people and
economic interests have a right and need
to be to have their interests
represented but so to organize people
under the weight of money under the
overpowering flood of money that buys
access to the politician that buys the
policies of our government you know it's
a mistake to pay much attention at the
surface to a political campaign our
political campaigns are largely charades
behind which the serious largely
unscrupulous business of getting power
is played out because power is about the
spoils of victory it's about who gets
the tax breaks who gets the subsidies
who gets the benefits and for 25 years
there's been this growing power of
organized money there's also been the
cultural war defined by the moral
majority pat robertson and and and the
political right which is concentrated on
abortion gun control evolution though
is really quite frankly marginal issues
marginal to the fundamental basic
question of economics I mean and and the
and and a lot of people have been voting
against their own economic interest by
voting on cultural issues there's a
powerful but one of the best political
books I've read in the last ten years
called what's wrong with Kansas by young
journalist named Thomas Franks who has
just become the Washington correspondent
for Harper's Magazine by coincidence he
happens to be on our show Friday night
and he he has been to Kansas his native
state he asked the question what's wrong
with Kansas and he finds that in the in
the Midwest in the poorest County in
America with a income average income I
think of 6,000 some odd dollars they
vote 85% for the Republican Party and as
a serious journalist he wanted to know
why and he found out why because
abortion gun control these other
cultural issues matter more to them they
think they matter more to them than in
economics and the Democratic Party has
gone on gone along with this when it
comes there's been a class war going on
in this country fought from the
boardrooms down now when I say that the
Wall Street Journal any progressive who
says that's going to get slammed by The
Wall Street Journal of others for
talking about class war but they started
the class war and in the class war the
Democratic Party has gone awl they're
not they're fighting or fighting
fighting for Social Security fighting
for increasing the minimum wage fighting
against the the munition of retirement
fighting against these big corporate
subsidies and so the answer to your
question is only when people get
organized and fight back will you ever
make a dent
yes sir
on the subject of patriotism I heard
it's been said that patriotism is the
last refuge of the scoundrel if I may is
a question similar to the one I asked
Mario Cuomo and Jules Feiffer at their
book signing my rage prevents me from
finishing worse than Watergate by John
Dean and after seeing Fahrenheit 9/11 I
had tears of rage
do you experience such rage and how do
you deal with it when these
mean-spirited ones of our society is
ruining our country the world and this
planet how do you deal with that rage I
guess my journalism is a big therapeutic
factor in that in that I can take an
idea and get it out to share with other
people I am you journalism has been a
continuing course in adult education for
me and I've been blessed with a large
classroom that I can share what I
learned with and that that helps me it
helps me to I mean I do believe in
informing people I think that's helpful
as I said I don't want to claim too much
for journalism I don't claim too little
so so getting a story out we did a story
two weeks ago
oh now about the abuse of power and
money a Tom DeLay the majority leader of
the house who's engaged in some really
scandalous 5-card money with with hid
with his office and in that that that
helps to get it out it helps to know
that people saw it and are responding to
that helps then you know I we each have
our own DNA why does somebody commit
suicide after a tragedy and someone else
doesn't I don't know how to live my life
without expecting a confident future and
then getting up every wanting to do
something about it now I happen to be
able to do more about it in the terms of
a public platform then then you do but
some way to turn that anger into an
affirmation to get in the fight I did
this series with Jose
Campbell I remember he he told about the
Irishman who was coming down the street
saw a brawl and he he ran over to the
ball he said is this a private fighter
can anybody get in it and and the fact
of the matter is democracy's up is a
public fight you got to find any way you
can to get in it even against the odds
and the odds are great today but that's
the it's healthy to get angry sometimes
and there's plenty in our society to be
righteously indignant about the walls
the New York Times back in March on one
page had two stories on education one of
them told of how in New York the cost of
kindergarten this year in private
schools would be $26,000 a year on the
same page it was a story by Michael
Weinreb about the school the big largely
black school in in in Yonkers that
during Black History Month the kids went
to the library to see if they could find
some books about black heroes there was
no book about a black hero after 1969
there's no no card catalog in the
library the only recent books have been
Newbery Award books bought by the
teacher herself I mean that's something
to get mad about the disparity in in an
income the inequality today is the worst
statistically since 1929 that's
something to get mad about and then to
do something about and it sounds like a
bromide a platitude of piety but I don't
know what to do except find something at
hand that you can make a difference on
and then hope that someday that spark
comes and that movement begins that
brings back to people a desire to join
in a large and and and cooperative
political fight yes yes in your
estimation did Michael Moore get it
right and if he got it right well his
film make a difference
or are Americans too apathetic or
perhaps too polarized I can't answer
that question about whether Michael
Moore got it right because like because
I haven't seen the movie yet and will it
have a difference I do I think it
matters to preach to the choir I grew up
in a in a in a little Baptist Church in
East Texas and sometimes on a cold
winter night or a stormy Sunday morning
only the choir showed up and and they
they I I believe in preaching the choir
because the choir has to keep singing
until people keep coming and so so on
his side of mean I'm as I said I've been
I lived in the South I work for Lyndon
Johnson I'm weary of propaganda we will
live in a world of propaganda our job as
a journalist as tries to get as close as
possible to the verifiable truth and and
to admit it when we haven't gotten all
the way there there's a role for
propaganda I worry about a polarization
in society where we only fight our
political battles with propaganda
because I believe if you infuse
entertainment too much into the
political dialogue and into the
documentary you run the risk of
forgetting how to conduct a reasoned
argument and try to persuade your
opponent but the fact of the matter is
the Michael Moore's of the right have
been doing this for for 25 years now and
it's about time the other side had a
Michael Moore who knew how to how to
fight back
the recent silence surrounding the
American culture revolution since Niall
8 819 ages thousands of highly educated
competent in honest people have been
fired and black fired from nonprofit
sector and blacklisted as the
doorstation of non profit is scale so it
can you explain this silence we talk
about the corrupt CEOs or corporations
we don't put them in prison
unfortunately but we don't even mention
the corrupt CEOs of non profit it can
you explain this silence I didn't
understand the question
my son is you speak right into the
microphone ok I'm sorry that's right why
there is silence surrounding the
devastation of non profit we even the
corrupt a corporate culture enter non
profit we have the same CEOs with no
accountability there is terror in non
profit and the places are much more
abound and people in these places
I mean museums research libraries people
are much more vulnerable but because
there is no money
our brave liberal lawyers don't touch
the issue I think for the same reason
our brain liberal journalists don't
touch the issue it's a serious problem
because instead of highly educated
competent in honest professionals
because I would bar over cabinet
apparatchiks and feeling executioner's
it's devastating and I think this issue
should be addressed I can tell that your
point is coming from some deep
experience but I don't know enough about
that particular issue to give you a
responsible answer I do you know I do
know that we have a serious issue in
America with governance of all
institutions yes because we have turned
so many of those institutions over to
managers and then we the people the
public the constituents sort of sit back
and and and and let the managers run
institutions there's a wonderful book by
theta scopa of harvard university
talking about how part of the reason
for the reason part of the reason for
the decline in civic participation and
in institutional governance is because
we've let the experts blind us to their
inabilities as as managers and we as
constituents of the library or public
television or whatever have not kept
vigil sufficiently to challenge them but
I can't say much more than that kind of
generality thank you I think that's all
we have time before now mr. Moyers we
thank you indeed for coming you've been
a very good artist thank you very much